i'm sumi somaskanda it's good to have
you with us
a last goodbye to george floyd the black
man whose death
ignited global protests against racism
and police brutality will be buried
today in houston
his hometown largely unknown in life
floyd's killing two weeks ago after a
police officer knelt on his neck
now appears to be a turning point in
american history
under a scorching texas sky thousands
queued for hours
to enter the church where george floyd's
body lay
a last chance for the public to pay
their respects to the man whose death
has become a rallying cry against racism
around the globe
the public viewing was held in houston
the city where floyd grew up
well this is an important time in our
world
and i feel that it is necessary
for me to be here number one as a human
being
for the human race and then me being an
african-american man
it is i wouldn't miss this for the world
white people have the luxury
of assuming the police are good and
assuming the police are on their side
but the reality is is that black people
don't have that luxury in america
also attending the families of other
black victims of police brutality
i stand in solidarity with this family
because it mimics my case and this is
personal to me
they have doubled back and claimed
another life
by a chokehold that's why we have to
fight for justice yes ma'am
in washington democratic senators knelt
in silence for eight minutes and 46
seconds
the length of time floyd a black man was
pinned under a white police officer's
knee before he died
you see how long it was to have
that knee on his neck
democrats in congress have proposed
sweeping legislation to overhaul u.s
police oversight that would include
banning chokeholds today
this movement of that moment of national
anguish is being transformed
into a movement of national action as
americans from across the country
peacefully protest
to demand an end to injustice
today with the justice and policing act
the congress is standing with those
fighting for justice and taking action
floyd's family and friends will hold a
private funeral service on tuesday in
houston
to remember the life of the man who in
death
has become an international symbol of
injustice
dw reporter stacey bivens is following
this story for us hi stacy
we've seen this outpouring of grief for
george floyd we heard there that he'll
be buried in houston today do you think
we're going to see the same types of
crowds turning out for this
i think today is a private moment this
is for the family
the past few days we've seen people come
out and collectively grieve
to come out and support the family and
to show sympathy for a man that they
watch die under the weight of police
but today he's going to be laid to rest
next to his mother
and surrounded by family and friends
let's talk about what happens next as we
look at these moments of mourning
we've seen the democrats who saw our
report there are looking at legislation
at this point
to tackle police culture to tackle
police misconduct
how do you change police culture because
that is a big task
the biggest hurdle is the police union
they are extremely
extremely powerful they have a lot of
money their coffers come from membership
dues
and so they're able to pay to
essentially block legislation to keep
their police powers in order to
influence elections
in order to get certain people elected
and in order to
in some cases get bad cops rehired
so what's happening in congress is
important because this means that they
are listening or
attempting to listen to the protesters
so
what they're proposing would make a
chokehold
illegal so what killed eric gardner and
what killed
um george floyd no knock warrants which
is how brianna taylor we've heard her
name
shouted at a protest was killed
and they would also make a registry so
that we can keep track
of bad cops and so when one is fired in
a one district
they can't get hired in another where
has the president
donald trump been in all of this because
a lot of people have been looking to the
white house for leadership
perhaps some signs to unite the country
and we haven't heard that coming from
the white house so
where has has he been that's a great
question he's been
sequestered behind that wall he recently
built around the white house
um i think it's easy to talk about what
he hasn't done
he hasn't met with black lives matter um
organizers he hasn't met with civil
rights leaders
he hasn't met privately with the george
or george floyd's family
but what he has done is retweeted
character
assassinations about george floyd um
on twitter that they come that came from
conservative commentators
and he also created a paraded a bunch of
middle-aged white men
on the sunday morning talk shows to say
that systematic racism in the police
department and to police departments
do not exist now he supposed
there's talk that he might hold some
kind of a
a talk in order to talk about civil
rights and bringing the nation together
but if he does that he's waited a long
time traditionally presidents get out in
front
of something like this to bring the
nation together but he's as you said
he's been absent
dw reporter stacy bivens thank you